foreign
so Indiana Jones in the dial of Destiny
is the news the fifth Indiana Jones film
Harrison Ford's back as Indiana Jones in
his Fifth and final Indiana Jones
adventure and the way that all right the
movie started out actually pretty
awesome it started out great it was kind
of works against the movie as a whole in
that rule of contrast kind of way
because the first 20 minutes or so of
this movie is dharison forward its young
Indie taking on Nazis trying to keep
them from getting power when they're on
their last leg if there was a fourth
Indiana Jones movie I would have wanted
in the first place would have been that
for being honest with myself the D aging
actually looked really good but there
were some moments when he was talking
the lips didn't quite sync up then the
rest of the movie keeps going on and you
just can't help but have thoughts all
right first of all there are moments in
here where it does feel like oh hey some
cool-ish Indiana Jones stuff is
happening I mean yeah they try to
overcook the chase sequences to the
point where it's clearly CGI clearly
green screen and it stands out Indiana
Jones fighting the Nazis on those tanks
and Last Crusade moves a lot slower also
much more intense because it feels real
it feels like real Peril I mean there's
one Chase sequence where someone's
chasing after a plane while they're on a
motorcycle at night in a downpour and
I'm like I can't see anything I'm sure
it's great because if dark and or
nighttime scenes hide CGI well you know
dark end or nighttime scenes during a
downpour that's really going to hide it
that's what it feels like it doesn't
feel organic doesn't feel exciting just
feels like camouflage so Phoebe Waller
Bridge plays Indiana Jones's goddaughter
because back in 1944 Indiana Jones had
this friend he was so close to played by
Toby Jones we never saw him in any of
the other Indiana Jones movies but he
was so close to this friend that this
friend named Indy The Godfather of his
daughter fair enough so they're on this
adventure together and I gotta say
they're Dynamic together I wasn't a fan
of it I wasn't buying it just felt like
their characters seemed annoyed with
each other for most the time maybe I
find it more Anno because there is
something interesting there because
Phoebe Waller Bridge's character her
life is a complete and total disaster
it's almost like the movie doesn't want
you to think that but it is while
they're in this Chase sequence she says
something to Indy about being
self-sufficient or something like that
I'm like no your life is a mess you're
in this Chase sequence with this
ex-fiance slash mobster who didn't
matter before this Chase sequence and
will not matter after they just
apparently need something to puff up the
run time so out of the blue Chase
sequence why not so the dynamic of her
life and indie's life indeed now being
this old grumpy alcoholic very depressed
old man the dynamic between the two
could absolutely work the movie it never
actually allows these two characters to
grow together or have the conversation
or even address the fact that yeah both
of our lives are a mess and we're both
miserable so maybe we're actually
finding something enjoyable through this
and we're helping each other out you can
make the argument the movie does end up
doing that but it's not organic it just
kind of feels out of the blue this feels
like there were two characters who were
at odds kind of annoyed with each other
for most of the movie and then they'll
have this out of the blue out of
character Heart to Heart On A Boat where
you find out how and why they wrote off
poochie the dog and that's a frustration
because it's not just with that
character Dynamic there are a couple
things in here where it just tease it up
there's a layup and they never take it
it's like why did you why do you have
that this mixes with this so well to
make well nothing you're doing nothing
with it
Fair it all deals with spoilers friends
I can't talk about it here but a sec now
they got John Williams back to score the
musical score for this movie and you
absolutely feel it it's a standout
there's nothing quite like a John
Williams musical score he's the master
at work what can you say he's one of the
greatest composers in history not film
history Earth's music is the heart and
soul of life itself my friends John
Williams
a few others their work makes life feel
lived mads Mickelson shows up to work he
always does though it's like all right
we need a really stoic soft-spoken scary
person to just fill the room and own
every scene he's in doesn't even have to
do much just say the lines who we got
mads Mickelson absolutely of course the
man's a professional he always clocks on
to work he did in that third bad
Fantastic Beasts movie mads Mickelson
doesn't phone it in he also
ridiculous man you ever forget about
something until you're talking about the
movie
and then here it is just pop back in my
head he takes a hit in this film that's
not unlike the one that killed Dennis
Hopper in speed
only it was faster here I was waiting
for some magical explanation you know
dial of Destiny maybe that no he just he
just survived it no concussion no Mark
no nothing that was when I was like okay
so it's gonna be like that people are
just gonna live through stuff well
Indy's also bomb proof I'm not talking
about the nuke fridge thing from later
on in his life I'm saying in the
flashback scene the DH scene yeah he's
bomb proof apparently I mean there could
be a whole philosophical debate actors
age so their characters generally
speaking but they're gonna have to age
with them but at the point the character
ceases to feel like the character you
knew from those movies
well should it even happen I say no let
the character retire you know like the
character did in Last Crusade when he
his father and his friends rode off into
the sunset in a movie titled the Last
Crusade Studios being studios are like
it ended
but we can pump out more right do it
it's got to be organic It's gotta make
sense however Sean Connery and Last
Crusade he was older but he still had
that
adventure for Life Andy doesn't have
that in here Indy in this movie is an
old miserable drunk who feels slightly
more miserable than Brendan Fraser's
character in the whale did so the
conversation really boils down to the
difference between movies ending and
dying because movies don't necessarily
die when they end if they end right end
well and in a timely manner because
someone can responsibly be like it's
time to end that story and that
character they become something else
entirely I don't want to plagiarize
Batman Begins by saying a legend Mr
Wayne but it's definitely not unlike
that yeah immortality for sure a film
series Ends by ending it dies by
pathetically hanging on past its
expiration date if we did that with
people who die we bury them we have the
funeral and then some years later we dig
them back up and bring them back to life
yet those are called zombies and that's
the phase we're in cinematic zombies is
this better or worse than kingdom of the
Crystal Skull it's actually a really
good question I haven't seen Crystal
Skull in eons I have the set and I have
not watched the movie from the disc in
the set that I own I just call it three
movies in a coaster so it's hard for me
to judge I haven't seen Crystal Skull
but in its entirety since it was in
theaters however uh Crystal Skull is
about a half an hour shorter than dial
of Destiny so there is that that's not
nothing that's my final point this movie
is too long what is this fetish with
making movies run time now the norm is
two and a half to three hours stop so
that's where I am with dial of Destiny
it felt like Indiana Jones emulation it
had some of the exciting bits some of
which was entertaining all of which was
faster than it was in the previous
Indiana Jones movies but not more
exciting those are two very different
things I feel like I summed it up at the
beginning of this review so sorry for
wasting your time for the next few
minutes the first 20 minutes or so is
the most interesting Indiana Jones
sequel in the movie the rest of the film
never lived up to that intro the movie
has potential like on paper and concept
I can see how they were like hey this
should work which makes me think there's
probably a four hour cut of this movie
out there somewhere in which it all
mixes so much better like I'm never
gonna watch this movie again I have to
think about it Indiana Jones movie how
often am I going to watch this I'm never
gonna re-watch it just left me with a
state of indifference and for me that's
the worst that's a killer the feeling
where I'm not gonna remember this in
T-minus one day yep already forgot all
right so Indiana Jones and the dial of
Destiny have you seen it what did you
think about it or what are your rankings
for the Indiana Jones movies favorite
the least favorite whatever they are
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]